my country saved me my country saved me
and I cannot forget it and I will fight
for her as long as I draw breath so help
me God
the last great act of political figure
of the 20th century has lost his battle
with cancer at age 81 John McCain former
prisoner of war and two-time
presidential candidate was a man
propelled by his interpretation of the
honor code to defy his Vietnamese
captors criticized Republican
politicians including Donald Trump and
ultimately to support some of the most
interventionist foreign policy --zz in
modern American history the namesake son
and grandson of well-known Navy Admirals
McCain initially rebelled against his
military destiny famously graduating 890
forth out of an Annapolis class of 899
he drank and cussed dated Florida
strippers and Brazilian heiresses and
crashed an alarming number of planes
before settling down to the family
business of war
McCain was on the deck of the USS
forrestal when a stray bomb ignited a
fire killing 134 servicemen the most
deadly accidents in the US Navy history
and then the first bomb exploded this
complete knocked me about ten feet and
everyone who had been near me were all
either badly maimed or killed from this
explosion yesterday over Hanoi Breen
American planes were shot down and at
least two of their pilots captured one
of them was Lieutenant Commander John
McCain birth the son of the u.s. naval
commander in Europe I was on a flight
over the city of Hanoi and I was firing
the aircraft fire not ejected
and into haha light the Aviators
rebellious nature served him well over
the next five and a half years as he
inspired cell mates with loud acts of
defiance and quiet organization of
internal communication systems despite
enduring torture that permanently
damaged his body this experience
combined with a domestic discord he
witnessed upon returning stateside in
1973 damaged his faith in American
foreign policy as a congressman McCain
opposed Ronald Reagan sending Marines to
Beirut as a senator he criticized Bill
Clinton's nation-building adventures in
Somalia and Haiti and described u.s.
military involvement in Yugoslavia as
the aspect of the future of this nation
that bothers me more than anything else
yet by 1998 McCain would emerge as the
Senate's leading hawk so what happened
the unexpectedly easy military successes
in the Gulf War in Yugoslavia coupled
with the vacuum and post Cold War global
leadership led McCain to re-embrace a
Teddy Roosevelt style belief in American
military supremacy and to wave off
Vietnam as some sort of anomaly our loss
in Vietnam afflicted America with a kind
of identity crisis he wrote in his 1998
memoir faith of my father's we should
never have let this one mistake terrible
though it was color our perceptions
forever
I thought I would tell Senator McCain he
is a man of profound personal courage
and the suffering and service he gave
this country ought to be honored for
most of McCain's political career he was
the media's favorite Republican I bet it
we were all rooted for you by the way a
lot of us in this business like John
McCain a lot but the wonderful thing
about McCain always has been that he is
a maverick Hillary Clinton has said that
you are her favorite Republican the
mutual love affair with what McCain once
described as his base in the national
media soured once he won the Republican
nomination but even in 2008 the press
frequently mistook his pragmatism for a
lack of ideology in fact it was anything
but the Arizona senator has long had an
alarmingly Marshall view of citizenship
in which individualism must be subsumed
to the greater good President Bush has
talked about our saying
in Iraq for 50 years maybe a hundred
that'd be fine with me arrogance as long
as Americans are not being injured or
harmed or wounded or killed his longest
war was against what he called corrosive
cynicism which meant that anything
creating more of the stuff from steroids
and bass bolts of political advertising
on Facebook was in his crosshairs the
same sense of high moral dudgeon could
also take him to better places such as
his opposition to torture and annual
attacks on pentagon waste understandably
it's McCain's profound sense of honor
that obituaries will be emphasizing in
the coming days with his health
deteriorating in 2017 the senator led a
global tour to reassure nervous American
allies called out eruptions of
conservative bigotry and cast the
deciding vote against the flawed repeal
of Obamacare turning the thumbs down on
the repealed
the open-ended interventionism the
senator championed in his final two
decades led to some of the most tragic
policy failures of our time there is
also honor in seeking a more humble
conception of America's role in the
world
farewell John McCain you will make
sacrifices for your fellow Americans who
won't be asked to make sacrifices for
you it is a noble cause it is your cause
and it's worth living and dying for may
your lives be as lucky as mine Godspeed
Semper Fidelis fair winds and following
seas
[Music]